so the for honor battle pass is now
alive year 4 season 1 a new hope is some
I call it is finally upon us and we can
now play it and it's actually a hell of
a lot of fun I'll save my opinion of the
battle pass for a future video probably
going live on the same day that you're
seeing this video but regardless I've
been grinding a pretty big amount I'm
actually like tier 24 at the moment I
believe I'm a little bit higher but to
be fair majority of those reps and ranks
were because I was actually buying the
tiers but I did grind my way to get some
of this stuff especially for this video
and it stats that we were doing either
way there is a lot of stuff to earn in
the battle pass being weapons execution
steel salvage and a whole lot more so
we're gonna discuss how to get that d
fastest way possible in the most
efficient way possible so first up you
can earn progress towards the past by
completing the daily challenges
finishing our Kaede quests and playing
matches matches are gonna be about time
played which we'll get into a little bit
later but as for the math on the dailies
you get 150 battle points per day with
the dailies one being a hundred and one
being 50 battle points each rank is 300
battle points so it would take you
roughly two days to get one rank or 200
days to unlock the entire thing except
at the maximum we have 83 days to
complete this it might be a little bit
lower depending on when you're watching
this so definitely keep that in mind
you're gonna need a total amount of
thirty thousand points for all 100 tiers
and doing the dailies every day from now
when this video goes live will give you
about twelve thousand four hundred and
fifty points or roughly forty one and a
half tears for the pass obviously some
dailies require kills and doing matches
so you'll get the bonus xp for that for
example I had a challenge that gave me a
hundred battle points but I actually
ended up earning a hundred and
eighty-five because the extra time
played I did during that Dominion game
that's gonna be different for player
everyone's gonna be getting different
dailies so let's just assume it's tier
fifty-two tier 55 you get from doing the
XP from the games you play to complete
the daily orders and the daily orders in
general but that has to be done from now
until the end of the battle pass either
way we still run into a predicaments
because 50 and 55 is not 100 it is far
from that so we need to get
that extra little bit of XP so we
decided to look at some of the game
modes I ended up choosing Arcade first
because I remember from the event quest
that arcade is the best way possible to
get a lot of the event loot so I thought
it would be the same
I tested arcade first using the weekly
quest that comes up and changes every
week and then those random quests people
kind of play every now and then and each
of them took around 10 to 15 minutes to
complete I was having a little bit of
trouble and I wanted to make the times a
little bit more even the weekly ended up
giving me 49 points and the other random
quest gave me 19 so definitely not a
good idea for that the only too obvious
modes we have left are breached in
Dominion and then their respective PvP
and AI game modes I tested both and got
these numbers breach ended up giving me
a hundred and fifty ish points for about
a twenty minute game of breach with
actual players and Dominion it gave me
about 75 to 85 for about a nine to ten
minute match both with PvP I then tested
AI Dominion with matchmaking on and off
and I got forty seven and forty four
points respectively so not as high as
I'd like it for the time that we spent
doing that I then decided to test a
breach AI and breach AI got me ninety
nine points in about eight minutes which
is one less than Dominion PvP that being
a nine minute game and you're actually
getting more points so it's really
beneficial but the issue is that it was
a first phase and of course this is
before breach 2.0 I got lucky with the
fact that I was being picked as a
defender and we wiped out the attackers
in the very first phase and of course
because during this game mode of breach
the attackers lose live at this point
breach 2.0 has not been implemented at
the time that I'm making this video so
if it is implemented this stuff may
change just a tad bit but at the moment
breach 2.0 does not exist and we still
have the original breach back in
marching fire so lives do count during
the very first phase which is why we got
so many points as such a quick amount of
time
so ending up going on the attacker side
and we ended up getting a hundred and
thirty-three points in 16 minutes which
is for less than PvP breach but also 21
points less so that's up to you whether
you want to go through with that or not
one thing is for sure though if you do
have the premium pass you're going to be
earning a
a 10% increase on the battle points I
did not put those numbers into the
equation I do believe that the breach AI
game-mode that I played all the way up
to defeating in the commander was
actually like a hundred and forty five
but because you know that's a whole
different thing and some people might
not have the premium pass and they might
have the free pass only I only counted
the regular amount that I earned from
the game not the extra additional stuff
so yeah for my honest opinion I honestly
think of breach AI is definitely the
move here the potential of scoring the
defenders side and getting some really
hefty points in little to no time
against the attackers is a really big
gamble but I think it's totally worth it
in the end and if you get the attackers
you could plow through it and get those
rewards as well obviously the only
problem with this is that breach in
general is a very long game mode and
grinding that for hours and hours upon
end can be incredibly boring so test out
a new controller for fun if you're a PC
player and use controllers such as
myself try to use a mouse which is what
I was doing for the gameplay obviously
you can always test out a new character
test out of no execution all that kind
of thing or if you're really really
really bored of breach and you do not
want to play the game mode
understandable Dominion PvP will
definitely be your second best option
it's not going to give you a hell of a
lot of points compared to breach per
game but it roughly evens out and I
think it's a good alternative if you
don't really feel like playing breach
so assuming my math is correct and you
all start out at tier 1 and you guys
didn't buy any of the tiers and you
completed the first two dailies that
came out as soon as the season went live
and you also did two preached games cuz
two dailies will give you 150 points and
roughly two breech games can get you
about 150 or more points all you have to
do is hop on every day do the two
dailies do two breech games every single
day so the very end of the battle pass
and you will get tier 100 on the very
last day obviously I would recommend
doing way more games than that because
that's cutting it down to the wire and
then what happens if you miss a day now
you have to double up on certain things
so I would just grind it to your heart's
content one day you know set a weekend
set a day aside a night aside and just
kind of go in on breach AI and get those
points rolling this has nothing to do
with getting it efficiently but I do
recommend in terms of saving steel this
is the way I always do battle passes is
that
all the way up until one of the few last
days and if it looks like I'm not gonna
be able to fully complete the entire
battle pass say him a couple that like a
couple days left in the battle pass but
I have like ten tears to go
that is when I whip out the wallet or I
whip out the steel and I will purchase
my way to the end I would not recommend
purchasing it now because you're pretty
much ruining the grind and all the fun
but I get it if you're a person that's
very busy and strapped for time
that's why I included the dailies in the
two breech mode other than that let me
know if you guys think about this stuff
in the comments below I've already
talked about the battle path like I said
I'll be making a full dedicated video on
my thoughts on what I think about the
battle past what could be improved what
could be added all that kind of stuff
and also be taking some of your
suggestions so if you have any
suggestions or any thoughts on the
battle pass definitely leave it in the
comments below yeah but that guys like
the video if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side of foreigner that being the balance
changes the hero updates the patch notes
and the leaks if you want to be kept up
to date with everything happening within
the world of foreigner and never miss
out on an update that if we stay
subscribe to the channel the guys take
care or ghosted a peace out and enjoy
the grind
[Music]
you
[Music]